and on the mound a three-time winner
with the scion
top five finishers seven of the last
eight seasons acquired from washington
at the trade deadline
tonight making his dodger debut it's max
scherzer
another big game pitcher in this dodger
rotation if it's kirschoff it's bueller
and now
scherzer this is an absolutely great
addition
to this likes deals rotation two
friends takes him out with a festival
the mac sure era in los angeles opens
with a punch out of altuve
a lot of it bats over the years for
michael brantley against max
brantley drives one deep to right field
hooking this ball
is fair and gone home run
michael brantley astros on the board
first
one nothing against scherzer second
batter he faces
michael's second career home run off of
scherzer
in his 50th career at bat came in
batting 347
against the three-time cy young award
winner great second two gun and a 3-2
coming from scherzer
fastball bullseye strike three book mk
is in the first inning for max scherzer
home run from michael brantley though
and it's one-nothing
astros as the dodgers come off the bat
on the mount for your astros
is jake odorizzi 14 games this season 13
of those have been starts
he has a four and five record that whip
at 1.14 54 strikeouts
and a pretty good average against it
222. mookie betts
who had a single and a walk yesterday
drives this spot in the air to center
field sending tucker back
track it's gone it's
tied
he's gone from he is heating up to he is
hot with this pitch a breaking ball that
he supplies the power in the back spin
he crushed it
swinging emmaus so to rizzy picks up a
strikeout justin turner goes down
swinging one away in the inning
and now will smith 2-0 driven into here
to deep right field
bradley's going back he's at the trap
he's at the right
that way
dodgers 4-1 and we're not
finished with the first it did go down
it did and he's in the right uniform
he's throwing 2-2
and getting tucker for the first out of
the second
swing and miss stuff he is at it again
five swings and misses so far here
uh change up gets garcia swinging back
to back haze to open the second and what
that means is that
he had the right to veto any trade
struck out tucker
struck out garcia castro flips this one
in the ear to left center
pollock to finish off a one two three
second from matt scherzer
back to the top of the order mookie beth
started the game with a home run
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no backflip that felt so good i don't
want to let go
new set of 52 000 fans sharing their own
distance
[Applause]
his fifth total time taylor at first
after the two out walk
two balls and two strikes here comes
pollock turns on a ball high drive left
field
forget about it long gone
went from a running situation to a
stroll
chris taylor just jogged
watch this one
who might have been in one of those
lineups when he pitched against the
astros in 2009
i know somebody grew who me kyle tucker
in the shallow center field and that
will
be down for a hit coming in from third
is jordan alvarez he'll score for some
reason chris taylor
tries to get the runner at home played
an air mail's home plate so that'll cost
him an error
as tucker moves into second base
crack back fly ball right center field
taylor's there for this one and then we
do it for the astros in the fourth
they get one but the dodgers lead 7-2
jason castro leading off this fifth for
the astros in a 7-2 game
destroys the bat with this fast spot on
the hands
muncie to the bag one ground in the
fifth cheers in the colors for the
one-two pitch
he strikes him out with the change up
owens who on jose twoway who has struck
out both times against shirley
he's struck him out all three times
tonight
this is where you get that home stretch
where you're maybe pace facing some
lesser talent some opportunities to put
up some numbers individually
correa to altuve the turn in time for
the double play aj pollock bounces into
an inning ending double play
good job by rafael montero after
allowing a couple of base runners we are
through
five it's 7-2 he goes from
calm to aggressive and he starts the
engine right
him out his here of the game
fly ball to left field pilot comes on
sega goes out it's coley seeger to put
it away
and end the six
max scherzer and his dodger debut back
out there for the seventh inning
strikes your mouth like a house by the
side of the road
watching strikeout number nine for
scherzer scherzer has three
ten strikeout games this year
a curtain call in his dodger debut
[Applause]
two of the best hitters in baseball
eltouve and brantley
down on strikes against joe kelly carlos
one for three tonight
and he drives one deep to left field
carlos correa has hit another home run
against joe kelly
a 2-2 pitch lonson launched into the
seats in the left
and correa picks up home run number 17
on the season and the astros now down
7-3 tucker knocked in a run with an rbi
single in the fourth inning
as he drives one deep to right field all
the way back this ball gone
two run home run kyle tucker astros
within two
it's now seven to five three balls two
strikes two outs jansen the myers